On le voyait en introduction,
les océans vivent des
bouleversements sans précédent.
Mais quel est l'impact sur
les êtres vivants qui habitent
ces écosystèmes marins? À l'ère
des changements climatiques,
y a-t-il des gagnants et des
perdants? Cap sur le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
♪ ♪ ♪
- (narrateur): Le golfe du
Saint-Laurent est une immense
mer intérieure. Dans les
villages côtiers, les bateaux
de pêche déchargent de leurs
cales des poissons, des
crustacés et des holothuries.
Mais si, à première vue,
l'activité semble prospère,
tout n'est pas rose au large.
♪ ♪ ♪
Le golfe subit les contrecoups
des bouleversements qui
secouent les océans partout
sur la planète.
Au quai de Rivière-au-Renard,
en Gaspésie, la saison de pêche
à la crevette bat son plein.
- Ils étaient ben juste sur
notre bord à nous autres.
- Comme la plupart des pêcheurs,
Mario Côté et son fils
Jean-Frédéric ont dû composer
avec les changements
qui affectent le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
- C'est sûr que l'eau s'est
réchauffée dans le golfe,
ça, on s'en rend tous compte.
- On peut pas s'en cacher
que ça fait peur tout ce
que c'est qu'on entend,
le réchauffement... T'sais,
c'est gros! Mais c'est-tu nous
autres la solution? C'est-tu...?
Ça, je me pose la question.
- Comme les pêcheurs,
les scientifiques canadiens
se posent des questions sur
l'impact qu'a le réchauffement
des eaux sur les espèces
marines. Pour le biologiste
Hugo Bourdages, tout n'est pas
blanc ou noir dans le golfe
du Saint-Laurent.
- Oui, il y en a qui vont
s'en tirer moins bien, mais
il y en a qui vont s'en tirer...
qui vont bien s'en tirer.
- Par exemple, le homard se
porte à merveille. Par contre,
des espèces comme le crabe
des neiges, la crevette et
le turbot ont déjà de la
difficulté à s'acclimater.
- Il n'y a pas de bon et de pas
bon dans ce réchauffement-là
qu'on observe.
C'est plus un déplacement
de nos espèces dans l'espace.
Il y a plusieurs exemples
d'espèces qui se portent bien
dans cet environnement-là
qui est changeant.
- C'est le cas du sébaste,
qui est devenu le nouveau roi
du Saint-Laurent.
- En 2011, 2012 et 2013,
on ne sait pas trop pourquoi
exactement, mais on a vraiment
gagné à la loterie, à savoir
qu'on a trois cohortes
importantes de sébastes qui
sont apparues puis qui vont
bientôt rentrer à des tailles
appréciables pour la pêche
commerciale.
- Le sébaste est un poisson de
fond qui peut vivre jusqu'à
75 ans. Comme ceux de la morue,
ses stocks ont chuté de façon
dramatique dans les années 80.
À tel point qu'il a fallu
imposer un moratoire sur
sa pêche. Mais contre toute
attente, des relevés récents
au chalut ont confirmé le retour
spectaculaire du sébaste dans
le golfe du Saint-Laurent.
- L'année dernière, d'après
nos estimés, 90 % de la biomasse
qu'on a attrapée dans le fond du
golfe représentait des sébastes.
Si on compare avec le passé,
c'était plutôt 10, 15 %.
- Dans la salle des bassins de
l'Institut Maurice-Lamontagne
à Mont-Joli, les chercheurs
Caroline Senay et Denis Chabot
explorent plusieurs hypothèses
pour tenter de comprendre
le rétablissement étonnant
des populations de sébastes.
- Celle qui semble la plus
plausible est que les sébastes
sont une des rares espèces qui
tirent plutôt bien leur épingle
du jeu face aux changements
climatiques.
- Les chercheurs ont capturé
800 sébastes dans le
Saint-Laurent pour les exposer
ensuite aux variations de
température et d'acidité qui
sont anticipées dans le golfe
d'ici la fin du siècle.
- Le but du projet, c'est
de pouvoir mieux prédire
la physiologie, les besoins
énergétiques, le taux de
croissance, le taux de survie du
sébaste aux conditions actuelles
et aux conditions futures.
- Une des victimes du retour en
force du sébaste est la crevette
nordique. Après avoir atteint
des niveaux d'abondance
historiques, sa population a
fortement décliné depuis 2010.
Pas surprenant, puisque le
sébaste a fait de la crevette
une de ses principales proies.
Une chose est certaine,
il y aura des gagnants et des
perdants ici comme ailleurs. Et
il faudra se montrer résilient,
car les changements que nous
vivons sont là pour durer.
- C'est clair que le golfe
du Saint-Laurent, dans 50 ans,
va être différent de celui
d'aujourd'hui. Donc il y aura
encore une biodiversité à ce
moment-là, mais on aura perdu
l'écosystème qu'on connaît
actuellement. Et à mes yeux,
c'est une perte pour la planète
et pour nous.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Ce bouleversement mondial
des écosystèmes est un enjeu
de taille. L'océan est la plus
grande source de protéines de la
planète. C'est le garde-manger
de plus de 3 milliards
d'humains. Et ce sont
les habitants des pays en
développement qui seront
les plus touchés. La raison :
le réchauffement de l'eau
provoque déjà le déplacement
de nombreuses espèces vers les
pôles et va laisser un vide
alimentaire dans les régions
tropicales.
Mais, selon certains
scientifiques, les changements
climatiques ne sont pas la seule
menace à la survie des stocks
de poissons.
- La surpêche, c'est la raison
principale du déclin de la santé
des océans parce que la surpêche
et la pêche, en fait, c'est fait
pour tuer des poissons.
- À Vancouver, au bord du
Pacifique, Daniel Pauly dresse
un constat accablant de
notre gestion des pêcheries.
Ce chercheur a consacré sa vie
à étudier l'impact des pêches
sur les stocks de poissons.
- Dans la plupart des pays,
la surpêche, c'est le résultat
d'une pêche incontrôlée.
Donc la pêche incontrôlée,
ça devient un peu une surpêche.
- Parmi les espèces qui sont
exploitées au maximum de
ce qu'elles peuvent endurer,
on pense au thon et au requin.
- La pêche ne produit rien.
La pêche ne fait que ramasser
ce que la nature produit.
Les poissons, c'est pas
le pêcheur qui les produit.
Il ne fait que les ramasser.
- Selon les chiffres recueillis
par l'ONU, 94 % des stocks de
poissons seraient à la limite
de leur exploitation ou bien
surexploités. Mais peut-être
est-ce davantage. Le problème,
c'est que trop souvent, on ne
sait pas avec précision ce que
les pêcheurs sortent de l'océan.
- La méconnaissance des prises
réelles des pêcheries mondiales
a caché une partie du déclin.
Encore aujourd'hui, on a
l'impression que les stocks se
maintiennent alors qu'en fait,
ils s'écroulent très souvent.
- Selon lui, une des solutions
pour en arriver à mettre en
place une pêche durable serait
d'arrêter de maintenir en vie
artificiellement cette activité
économique au détriment de la
ressource.
- Toute pêcherie qui a besoin
d'être subventionnée a besoin
d'être abandonnée parce qu'elle
ne devrait pas continuer.
Parce que la nature nous dit :
«Laissez-moi tranquille. Il faut
que je me repose. Il faut que
je me remette.» Et ce message
très clair que la nature
nous donne, on n'a pas besoin
de l'écouter quand on a
des subventions. Donc voilà,
on continue à pêcher malgré
le fait que les ressources
soient exterminées.
- Partout sur la planète,
les pêcheurs n'ont pas le choix;
ils devront continuer à
s'adapter.
- On va faire comme... on va
dire, comme mon père a fait
quand il a pris le bateau, comme
mon grand-père a fait aussi.
On va s'habituer avec ce
qui arrive en ce moment.
- Je peux pas croire que
du jour au lendemain, il n'y a
plus personne qui va pêcher
sur la terre. Il y a du monde
qui serait malheureux en
tabarouette. La planète au
complet est affectée là-dedans.
On a une grosse part de
responsabilité mondiale à faire,
pas juste pêcheurs. C'est
mondial que ça va être, là.